madame monsieur bonsoir bienvenue voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce dimanche
22 juillet une journée marquée par un
dramatique accident d'autocar en isère
le bus a plongé dans le lit d'un torrent
sur la commune de vizille près de
grenoble
50 pèlerins polonais étaient à bord le
bilan est lourd plus de 25 morts à
l'origine du drame des problèmes de
freinage sur une route très dangereuse
interdite à la circulation pour certains
autocars justement à un départ
d'incendié à nouveau dans le var cet
après midi à l'origine deux enfants de 9
et 10 ans qui jouer avec des allumettes
les pompiers ont pu très vite intervenir
reportage dans ce journal
mais où est passé pascal payet le
braqueur multirécidiviste qui s'est
évadé en hélicoptère le 14 juillet de la
prison de grasse est devenu l'homme le
plus recherché de france
nous ferons le point ce soir sur l'
enquête le tour de france avec le coup
de force une nouvelle fois de michael
rasmussen
le danois conserve le maillot jaune en
haut des pyrénées et ils creusent même
l'écart avec ses rivaux
l'autre vainqueur du jour est l'espagnol
contador qui remporte l'étape
enfin connaissez-vous les simpson homer
marge bart et les autres seront dès
mercredi sur grand écran le dessin animé
star de la télévision américaine arrive
au cinéma
toujours aussi déjanté et décalé fous
rires garantis
selon les spécialistes la pologne est en
deuil ce soir après le dramatique
accident qui s'est déroulé ce matin sur
la commune de vizille en isère ain
autocar transportant 50 pèlerins venus
de pologne a fini sa course dans un
ravin une chute de 40 mètres après des
problèmes de freinage sur une route très
pentu et dangereuse le bus a ensuite
pris feu
en contrebas le bilan ce soir est
extrêmement lourd il est de plus 25
morts le président de la république
nicolas sarkozy s'est rendu sur place
pour accueillir le président polonais
retour sur cette journée avec amaury
guibert une course folle une chute de
plus de 40 mètres il ne reste sur les
bords de la rivière qu'une carcasse
calcinée
décor que les pompiers extraient des
sacs et des valises qui jonchent le sol
la fin tragique du pélérinage de 50
polonais il est 9h30 passé lorsque leur
car s'engage dans la descente de laffrey
au bout un virage serré mais le bus ne
peut s'arrêter
il défonce le parapet du pont et
s'écrase dans le ravin en un instant il
prend feu à quelques mètres seulement
des maisons du village
je suis sorti j'ai évidemment vu une
fumée noire qui monte dans le ciel
depuis près j'ai vu des flammes entendu
une première explosion une seconde
et puis puis des flammes qui montaient
et la fumée qui envahissait le coin et
et voilà il et j'ai entendu des cris de
gens de tous côtés et déjà déjà à langer
sur l'assaut sur la chaussée et tour y
avait le quartier brûlés alors on
essayait de consoler les gens comme on
pouvait en étaient peu nombreux certains
rescapés ceux qui peuvent encore bouger
tente de s'échapper du bus en flammes
ils seront une poignée d'autres ont été
éjectées au moment de la chute ce qui
m'a plus marqué c'est ce petit enfant
qui cherchait sa mère étant grand mère
moi même c'est vrai que je vois ce gamin
de 13 ans qui s'est mis à pleurer parce
que sa mère il l'a trouvé pas c'est ce
qui m'a le plus marqué les riverains
seront les premiers à porter secours
avant l'arrivée rapide des pompiers les
blessés sont soignés à même le sol à
quelques mètres de la carcasse du bus
mais la plupart des passagers sont morts
soit sous la violence du choc soit dans
l'incendié le décompte des victimes
augmente d'heure en heure
l'ambulance
100 m 4
les guitares il nous manque de personnes
d'après match
de transport titre
mais bon on va lever le quart pour voir
ce cas là c'est son fax ou à 14h on
dénombre 26 morts mais ce décompte est
toujours provisoire car il ya quatorze
blessés graves
une situation exceptionnelle qui
délaisse ses cycles déclenchement d'un
plan rouge mobilise en plus d'une
centaine de pompiers
une quarantaine de véhicules des
hélicoptères peu avant 15h françois
fillon arrive sur les lieux avant d'être
rejoint par jean louis borloo ministre
de l'écologie en charge de la sécurité
routière
le premier ministre visiblement éprouvé
par la situation
je veux dire ma tristesse
ma douleur devant ce drame qui a frappé
des jeunes et des moins jeunes polonais
qui revenait d'un pèlerinage et qui
n'aurait jamais dû rencontrer l'amour il
y à moins d'une heure nicolas sarkozy
accueilli à l'aéroport de grenoble son
homologue polonais les deux chefs d'état
doivent se rendre à l'hôpital où sont
soignées les pèlerins blessés sur le
site de l'accident ce soir une grue
était en train de retirer du ravin la
carcasse de l'autocar la recherche de
corps est terminée mais l'identification
sera difficile beaucoup de victimes ont
été carbonisés une équipe de
spécialistes de l'institut de recherche
criminelle de la gendarmerie doit
d'ailleurs arrivé ce soir sur place et
ce drame s'est déroulé dans la descente
de laffrey sur la route napoléon cette
route située entre grenoble et gap était
déjà tristement célèbre on la savait
dangereuse et même meurtrière
puisqu'elle a été le théâtre de trois
catastrophes en 1970 en 73 et en 75 jean
françois feer et dans la descente de
laffrey où s'est produit l'accident
l'inclinaison et de 14% les panneaux de
signalisation traduit en trois langues
le rappelle la voix est dangereuse
strictement interdite aux camions comme
aux autos qu'un ce matin le chauffeur
polonais a donc enfreint la
réglementation faut être tout à fait
clair il n'y a que le transport régulier
de personnes sur ce secteur-là qui est
autorisé et qui fait l'objet de
l'association annuelles de la part du
gain sur la nationale 85 les seuls
transports en commun autorisés sont les
cars de ramassage scolaire
les autres doivent emprunter une
déviation la départementale 529 une
vingtaine de kilomètres plus tôt dans le
sens la mûre grenoble mais cette
déviation et plus longues et donc pas
toujours suivies passé on a frisé déjà
la même catastrophe mais le bus c'est
serré contre la paroi au niveau des
traverses
le chauffeur est élu estimant de sang
froid pour stopper son bruit et s'il
n'avait pas plu
le réel même la même catastrophe l'année
passée au mois de juillet ou août
n'était pas si courant n'at-il pas vu ou
pas compris les panneaux d'avertissement
le chauffeur polonais en tout cas
connaissais le danger le propriétaire du
véhicule avaient mises en garde
j'ai pratiqué c'est route
personnellement parce que je suis le
propriétaire du bus et que je le conduis
moi même parfois c'est une route
dangereuse
j'ai averti mes collaborateurs des
dangers une fois l'autocar engagé que se
passe-t-il
selon les témoins il roule à vive allure
70 km/heure environ contre 40 autoriser
d'autres affirment que de la fumée
s'échappe de l'arrière du véhicule
les freins peut-être qu'ils ne
parviennent pas à ralentir l'autobus
engagés dans la descente
un problème de frein à l'origine déjà de
trois accidents majeurs au même endroit
en 1975 un car de pèlerins là aussi
seront versés dans des circonstances
similaires
29 morts une stèle à leur mémoire a été
érigée depuis trente ans la nationale 89
est l'une des routes les plus
meurtrières en france on retrouve sur
place maintenant l'une des habitantes de
la commune ne visent ils m'admirent sac
bonsoir votre maison est située à
quelques mètres de l'accident
d'abord vous êtes rendu très vite un sur
cet accident et vous avez pu soutenir
quelques rescapés je crois oui oui
absolument et notamment de jeunes
garçons dont un qui avait 13 ans qui
parlait pas donner une l'a dit tout de
suite
j'étais un petit peu embarrassé donc on
a parlé en anglais donc ce qui m'a un
petit peu rassurés sur le sort des
autres puisque je voyais des survivants
alors j'avais un peu d'espoir ma mère ça
qu'on l'a visitée autre chose on l'a vu
dans notre reportage cette route est
très très dangereuse oui extrêmement
dangereuses ou vie c'est une route qui
est une pente à 12% sur 7 km on ne le
prévoit pas au départ mais elle est
allée très dangereuse elle est interdite
en plus chaud plus de huit tonnes bon il
ya des contrevenants et malheureusement
les conséquences qu'on connaît
vous craignez ce jour 28 ans oui bien
sûr bien sûr oui nous ne sommes pas
fataliste pour autant même si nous avons
connu d'autres accidents de ce type qui
sont quand même des accidents
une ampleur extraordinaire mais
aujourd'hui je pense que tout le monde a
vraiment pris conscience
merci madame mears accès bien toujours
pris monsieur merci beaucoup merci et le
président polonais kachine si c'est donc
très vite rendus sur place symbole de
l'émotion ressentie par son pays et en
france la communauté polonaise est
également bien sûr sous le choc de ce
drame reportage elisa coudray laurent
des bois la spéciale de la télévision
nationale polonaise
la présentatrice de l'information 26 de
ses compatriotes ont trouvé la mort dans
un accident d'autocar dans le sud de la
france
premières images et premier réflexe des
proches dans cette colonne très croyante
trouver une consolation un réconfort
dans la prière et chacun tente de
récolter quelques informations
concernant sa cagnotte
quand nous avons des contacts avec les
hôpitaux français avec le consul de
pologne à paris et sommes en train
d'établir une liste des victimes sans
embauches ne pense qu à paris c'est
aussi vers l'église que se tournent les
membres de la communauté polonaise
ils sont plus de 200 mille en france cet
après midi à l'église notre dame de
l'assomption
les fidèles étaient plus nombreux qu'à
l'accoutumée
et
les premiers mots du prêtre sont pour le
drame
je sais que c'est une situation
extrêmement pénible
le car est entièrement calciné il n'y a
aucune chance de trouver de nouveaux
survivants
prions avec toute notre ferveur pour les
victimes de cet accident à la sortie les
visages sont graves
chacun se sent concerné
ça fais autre chose ça fait ça
sans ça va beaucoup mieux qu'il est
d'origine ça fait beaucoup de mal
j'ai pu enfin la tristesse je suis à
l'intérieur
fabrice dans les prochains jours la
communauté polonaise poursuivra son
deuil d'autres cérémonies religieuses
seront célébrées un peu partout en
france et l' enquête devra donc
déterminer les circonstances exactes de
l'accident un problème de freinage est
déjà avancé des questions autour du
système qui équipaient l'autocar
polonais sont posées pour ce type de
route quel est le dispositif
réglementaire quelles sont les normes de
sécurité
les explications de bruno timsit et
delphine pas rick miller
quand laurent rouleau prend le volant de
son auto car il est responsable de la
sécurité de plus de 50 personnes
première obligation pour pouvoir rouler
en france un système de freinage ultra
performant sur ce type de véhicule nous
avons un ralentisseur que l'on est en
route à l'aide de cette poignée il ya
jusqu'à cinq positions pour l'actionner
1 2 3 et maximum donc le véhicule
ralentit on immobilise offrant principal
par la suite en cas de pépin il reste le
frein de secours que l'on actionne
partidaire de cette façon et le véhicule
s'immobilise sur un autocar le contrôle
technique n'a pas lieu tous les deux ans
comme sur une voiture mais tous les six
mois
autre élément indispensable la ceinture
de sécurité pour les passagers
tous les véhicules immatriculés depuis
1999 doivent en être équipés du côté du
chauffeur le taux d'alcoolémie autorisé
n'est pas de 0 5 mai de 0,2 gramme par
litre de sang
une visite médicale est obligatoire tous
les 5 ans à partir de 60 ans et tous les
ans un chauffeur ne doit pas non plus
conduire plus de neuf heures par jour
c'est une norme européenne en france une
formation est obligatoire
ce n'est pas encore le cas dans tous les
autres pays européens en ce qui concerne
la formation
la france est nettement en avant même si
les directives européennes rendant
obligatoire cela en 2009
la france elle et les gens avancent et
applique ça depuis longtemps
contrôle technique ou compétence du
chauffeur se font les autorités du pays
d'origine qui sont chargés de ces
questions quand un quart étrangers
circulent en france seuls des contrôles
aléatoires peuvent permettre de
s'assurer qu'il respecte bien les normes
de sécurité
alors quelle est la situation ce soir
visible on retrouve denis sébastien sur
place la population et j'imagine
toujours très choqué après une telle
journée denis oui vous imaginez à 9h30
un dimanche matin en plein été un tel
drame dans leur jardin on peut dire
d'une certaine façon puisque le car
s'est écrasé en contrebas de leur maison
et ce sont eux ces habitants qui sont
allés porter secours les premiers donc
forcément ils sont tous très très
choquée ça a beaucoup marqué et je
dirais même qu au delà
au delà de ce choc il ya une certaine
colère puisque il dénonçait depuis des
années cette route dangereuse il y avait
eu des précédents plusieurs accidents on
l'a rappelé tout à l'heure donc ils sont
à la fois très marquée et et en même
temps en colère parce que il aurait
souhaité évidemment que ça ne se
produise pas ils avaient tous fait écrit
des lettres et sans qu'il y ait de
résultats merci denis un nouveau départ
d' incendies dans le var aujourd'hui les
pompiers ont pu intervenir très
rapidement cinq hectares sont cependant
partis en fumée et très vite on a
identifié les responsables une fillette
et un garçon de 9 et 10 ans qui
s'amusait avec des allumettes
reportage à tours près de brignoles
renaud bernard alain dumas
face au déploiement de force des secours
le feu n'a pas résisté
ce soir sur les contreforts de la
sainte-baume les pompiers noix les
dernières flammèches
les pierres continuent à garder la
chaleur
le cône est obligé de les arroser
le second police pour ce dimanche la
météo annoncée du vent les
sapeurs-pompiers du var étaient
prépositionnés dans tout le département
sur ce feu 200 hommes 40 camions ont pu
être mobilisés rapidement dans les airs
aux appareils de tous types ont été
déployés
s'il a été matraqué si on peut mais
aussi par sept canadair deux tracker et
le dash 8
dès le départ le seul souci actuellement
c'est uniquement l'accès il ya un seul
axe et un accès difficile pour un feu
provoqué par l'inconscience de deux
enfants de 9 et 10 ans à lui mais avec
paula s'est envolé et puis tout l'avant
voilà en ce moment les enfants et leurs
parents sont interrogés par les
gendarmes et le populaire parce qu'en
fait lui sauvé par l'intervention des
pompiers les habitants de la vie nets
sont en colère et des animaux et des cas
surtout il ya tout donné à tout le monde
que les parents et les enfants mineurs
sont pénalement irresponsable le parquet
de draguignan doit décider dans les
jours qui viennent
d'éventuelles poursuites contre leurs
parents
et puis d'autres incendie impressionnant
à l'étranger cette fois au sud de la
serbie à la frontière bulgare dans cette
région de l'europe
on souffre déjà depuis plusieurs jours
de la canicule avec des températures qui
vont au delà de 40 degrés est ses
départs d'incendié se multiplient en
raison de ses fortes chaleurs les
intempéries toujours direction
l'angleterre là bas ce sont toujours les
inondations qui perturbe l'ouest du pays
une situation qui pourrait s'étendre
selon le ministre de l'environnement des
pluies sont attendues dans les heures à
venir
la royal air force a déjà évacué une
centaine de personnes réfugiées sur le
toit de leur maison
le point ce soir avec maryse burgot
voici une anglaise qui se souviendra
longtemps de ce week end de juillet les
soldats de la royal air force ont ainsi
évacué plusieurs dizaines de personnes
dont des enfants
on a une personne handicapée qui doit
être évacué le plus vite possible
une opération de sauvetage sans
précédent en temps de paix plusieurs
comtés du centre ouest de l'angleterre
sont encore ce soir partiellement
inondées tous les moyens sont donc bons
pour venir en aide aux uns et aux autres
le bateau mais aussi parfois le
bulldozer
ces deux britanniques tentent
désespérément de sauver leur voiture ce
n'est pas gagné le plus simple est
encore de marché lorsque c'est possible
évidemment et pour ceux qui ne
souhaitent pas quitter leur maison
les sauveteurs libre de l'eau potable ce
commerçant d'evesham attendra à laitages
que le niveau veuille bien baisser au
début tout le monde trouve que c'est une
aventure surtout les enfants
mais quand on a plus d'eau courante ni
l'eau potable on commence à s'inquiéter
sérieusement comme toujours dans ces
situations dramatiques les critiques
envers le manque de préparation du
gouvernement ont commencé mais les
autorités expliquent que les
infrastructures ne sont pas en cause
c'est pluies torrentielles reste
exceptionnel mais avec le changement
climatique il est possible qu'elles le
deviennent beaucoup moins ont voté
aujourd'hui en turquie élections
législatives 43 millions de turcs
étaient invités à voter
les enjeux on sait sont multiples la
démocratie la place de l'islam la
laïcité et les premiers résultats donnés
ce soir par la télévision turque donnent
une large avance au parti du premier
ministre sortant recep erdogan
celui ci pourrait obtenir la majorité
absolue du parlement
la turquie qui reste en tout cas un
enjeu économique majeur pour l'europe
car elle est avec la russie l'autre
route privilégié pour l'acheminement du
gaz et du pétrole
un enjeu très important reportage en
pole chapelle fret sur le mans
escorte militaire sécurité maximale
c'est le terminal pétrolier qui fait la
fierté de la turquie est aujourd'hui une
fois les portables éteints sécurité
oblige il reçoit la visite intéressé
d'une délégation emmenée par la
commission européenne dans ce port de la
méditerranée des tankers prêt à
desservir le monde entier un million de
barils par jour en turquie on n'a pas de
pétrole mais on a des idées pour le
transporter 73% des réserves de gaz se
trouve tout près à l'est de la turquie
l'europe a besoin de ce gaz et du
pétrole
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles la
turquie devrait faire partie de l'union
européenne
le gaz de la mer caspienne qui traverse
la turquie intéresse l'europe
c'est désormais une alternative possible
au gaz qui vient aujourd'hui de russie
une stratégie argumenté du commissaire
européen chargé de l'énergie
la russie est toujours connu seul master
en droit ou à la négociation mais c'est
plus facile d'avoir la négocier avec les
russes il y a aussi les possibilités
d'avoir les autres fournisseurs et pour
accéder à ses fournisseurs
la turquie investi des gazoducs des
oléoducs parmi les plus longs du monde
transitent d'est en ouest du nord au sud
et même sur le bosphore au coeur
d'istanbul
les pétroliers traverse la turquie aussi
facilement que les bateaux de croisière
un argument supplémentaire pour les
diplomates
intrade lyonnais la face
donc la turquie doit faire partie de
l'ue ans
message bien reçu par les diplomates
européens jova rhdp et vous en ferez
reste à convaincre la france plus
réservés qui préfèrent que la turquie se
contente d'un partenariat privilégié
trait d'union entre l'europe et l'asie
la turquie a désormais l'ambition de
devenir aussi le carrefour international
de l'énergie et donc pour l'union
européenne un partenaire incontournable
en france est ce la fin d'une profession
depuis plusieurs semaines les pêcheurs
sont à nouveau sous le feu de
l'actualité une histoire longue fait de
crise de rebond mais aujourd'hui le
désespoir est là pour beaucoup et ce
soir nous avons voulu faire le point sur
cette profession en suivant l'un de ses
artisans pêcheurs à loctudy dans le sud
du finistère c'est le dossier de ce
journal reportage
martin gouès romuald de bonnan et
michelle sy vers 5 heures du matin sur
l'océan atlantique
jean marc ayrault mais parti pour une
journée de pêche pendant neuf heures il
va déposer selick à la palangre il
ramène du bar des sols et du rouget il
mise sur la qualité du poisson plus que
sur la quantité péché
nous ce qui nous sauve un peu c'est le
prix du poisson et comme on travaille
beaucoup avec la qualité de façon enfin
je partage pas beaucoup mais bon c'est
la qualité on s'en sort a à peu près au
large de loctudy dans le finistère il ya
deux ans ils n'étaient que deux à fait
chez comme lui aujourd'hui ils sont une
dizaine seul à bord ou presque une
question de survie pour ces pêcheurs
retour sur les années 80 et les rues de
bruxelles jean chey de poisson les
pêcheurs ont découvert les quotas à
cette époque chaque mois de décembre les
ministres de l'agriculture des sites des
quantités de poissons pêchés et des
primes offertes pour détruire les
bateaux trop vieux
quant aux cures
conséquence la colère des pêcheurs et
violentes comme ici à rennes en 1994
depuis 25 ans le nombre de bateaux
diminue plus de 11000 en 1983 on ne
compte plus que cinq mille 400 navires
en 2004
car le problème c'est la ressource trop
de bateaux pas assez de poissons disent
les scientifiques
faux répondent les pêches gabillaud il a
ainsi que de sept ans laissez le laisser
leur venir
les scientifiques nous disent oui il y
en a plus belle descente 8e cependant
loin le cabillaud en mer du nord serait
maintenant sauvées aujourd'hui c'est le
thon en méditerranée et l'anchois dans
le golfe de gascogne qui se fera les
français ne peuvent plus pêcher
l'anchois un poisson réservé aux
espagnols un choix politique
l'agriculture pour la france la pêche
pour nos voisins espagnols sont arrivés
au but de leur vie depuis quelques
années ils souhaitent anéantir la pêche
française sur balèze sur le choix et ils
y sont arrivés puisque évidemment que
cette crise va perturber terriblement
notre flottille et nous allons avoir
beaucoup de bateaux qui vont être
détruits des navires détruits ce sont
des emplois en moins en 2001 près de
quarante trois mille personnes
travaillaient autour de la pêche
elles ne sont plus que 18 milles car un
marin embarqué ce sont quatre emplois à
terre c'est d'abord toute la filière de
la pêche donc les mareyeurs les employés
de marée les employés du port et toutes
les entreprises de maintenance
et puis le commerce l'artisanat etc
toutes les entreprises qui travaillent
directement auprès de la pêche pourtant
le métier fait du encore tous les ans
1000 nouveaux pêcheurs s'embarque mais
le métier dur moins de la moitié
resteront cinq ans à bord voilà pour ces
explications on est toujours sans
nouvelles du petit thomas disparu il ya
8 jours à baratier dans les hautes-alpes
faute d'indicés sur le sort du garçon de
7 ans épileptique les gendarmes
privilégient la thèse de la noyade
demain les recherches reprendront avec
près de 50 tonnes
oser l'enfant avait échappé à la
surveillance de ses parents la famille
lit dans un camp de gens du voyage près
de la durance il est l'évadé du 14
juillet dernier pascal payet aidé par un
commando a réussi à s'échapper la
semaine dernière de la prison de grasse
en hélicoptère et aujourd'hui il est
l'un des hommes les plus recherchés de
france alors at il laissé des traces
derrière lui que sait-on des hommes qui
n'ont aidé à s'échapper
pour le moment les enquêteurs sont aussi
discrets que le fugitif
lionel feirstein damien louvet c'est
l'homme le plus recherché de france
pascal payet dit le roi de l'évasion est
en cavale depuis neuf jours le 14
juillet un commando l'a fait sortir de
la prison de grasse en hélicoptère
depuis personne ne l'a revu visé par un
mandat d'arrêt européen
il est également traqué en france par
des dizaines de policiers
tous les services sont dessus donc les
collègues sont sur les écoute 24 heures
sur 24 des balises on est posé sur les
véhicules pas seulement l'individu bien
entendu mais sur les personnes qui sont
en contact avec lui mais l'enquêté
s'annonce difficile car l'évasion de
pascal payet est un modèle du genre à
grasse son hélicoptère n'est resté que
cinq minutes sur le toit après
l'opération s'est déroulée en deux temps
une partie du commando a été déposée à
la roquette une autre à brignoles où
l'appareil a été abandonnée seuls
éléments laissés sur place selon le
journal du dimanche deux chargeurs de
kalachnikov une corde à une disqueuse à
moitié calciné les enquêteurs attendent
aujourd'hui le faux pas
quand on est en cavale comme ça il ya
plusieurs points de faiblesse
premièrement il faut trouver des faux
papiers là on risque de trouver de
tomber on peut tomber sur un indicateur
de police deuxièmement on a en général
envie de revoir les siens ses proches
et puis il ya évidemment l'argent car en
cavale tout coûte cher les faux papiers
l'hébergement en 2001 déjà pascal payet
s'était évadé par les airs il avait été
arrêté deux ans plus tard à la suite
d'un braquage en suisse le manque
d'argent pour sa clandestinité
il avait alors perdu en cette période
estivale les plaisanciers en
méditerranée sont nombreux et comme
chaque année une brigade en charge de
collecter les ordures les appelle les
éboueurs des mers l'an dernier près de
60 tonnes de déchets ont ainsi été
collectés sur seulement 30 kilomètres de
côtes
reportage près de cannes dans les
alpes-maritimes de renault bernard et
alain dumas une crique de cartes
postales au pied de l'estérel
il faut la nettoyer tous les jours
ce bateau est une benne à ordures il
sillonne toute la baie de cannes
les éboueurs travail à l'épuisette
c'est un travail de fourmi plage après
plage en sa présence
bonjour on procède au nettoyage de la
crique les nordistes n'avaient pas vu de
déchets en particulier place qui compte
en rien qu'une piquionne et bâle
la collecte est sans fin sur seulement
30 kilomètres de littoral
les éboueurs des mères récupèrent 60
tonnes de déchets chaque été deux ou
trois points de cette arrivée de
ramasser des joueurs funéraire sinon des
cas graves des cadavres d'animaux tels
que la nappe de dauphin de poisson lune
sinon
des débris humains une année un pied
êtes vous avez vu des macro déchets des
choses qui flottait la mise à part une
bouteille de bière qui au fond de
bouteilles de bière vides on se poile a
ses propres sur la côte d'azur les
éboueurs des maires font également de la
collecte d'ordures directement auprès
des plaisanciers pour faciliter leur
travail
un avion repères chaque matin les
concentrations de bateaux et 5,1 jetés à
bas ont fait plusieurs tournées dans la
journée j'ai trouvé ça génial c'est la
première fois que le wat ça fait 30 ans
qu'on fait du bateau et un homme mais
par contre c'est la deuxième année qu'on
ait la région autrement les texans assis
priaient
c'est la première fois qu'on voit ça
pour le moment cette collecte de déchets
sur l'eau n'existe qu'en région paca en
corse et sur une partie de la bretagne
le tour de france avant de revenir sur
l'étape d'aujourd'hui tout d'abord ce
sondage du journal du dimanche selon
lequel 78% des français ne croient pas
en l'honnêteté des vainqueurs autre
information qui met en exergue un
paradoxe les français continuent d'aimer
majoritairement le tour de france
toujours populaire mais en proie au
doute le public était nombreux
aujourd'hui encore pour suivre l'étape
du jour est à pyrénéenne on s'attendait
à une bagarre entre le kazakh vinokourov
et le maillot jaune rasmussen et bien
définitivement le danois est en ce
moment le plus fort très fort certaines
bières ou même trop fort n'at-elle de
rincquesen jean-marc notebook le tour
est arrivé dans les pyrénées mais les
coureurs n'ont pas vraiment eu le temps
d'apprécier le paysage peu après mazamet
six hommes dont cinq espagnols faussé
compagnie au peloton
ils prennent dix minutes d' avance pas
assez pour s'imposer les pyrénées c'est
le terrain de jeu des grimpeurs de colle
à franchir au port de pailhères
les meilleurs sont devant côté français
seul john gadret peut suivre le rythme
c'est mon film qui me convienne un peu
plus parce qu'en fait c'est un important
avantage de fruits dans les points
elle donc c'est pour ça que j'ai fait le
même monde et en leurs murs dès la
première ascension vinokourov dit
définitivement adieu à ses rêves de
victoire à paris aujourd'hui le kazakh a
perdu près de 30 minutes
loin devant lui rasmussen est passé à l'
attaque
seul l'espagnol contador arrivé à le
suivre
l'allemand clausen l'australien cadel
evans présentés comme ses deux plus
sérieux rivaux crack la fin de l'étape
ressemble à un petit arrangement entre
amis à toi le maillot jaune à moi la
victoire sur la ligne du plateau de
beille à 1800 mètres d'altitude
alberto contador s'impose au sprint
devant le maillot jaune désormais les
deux hommes occupent les deux premières
places du classement général christophe
moreau est arrivé 35 minutes plus tard
avec le gruppetto le peloton de ceux
pour qui les étapes de montagne sont un
véritable calvaire
alors je vous parlais de ce sondage des
doutes des français sur les champions
mais finalement là est le paradoxe de
cette épreuve sportive elle reste malgré
tout l'un des événements les plus
populaires au monde illustration avec le
public aujourd'hui dans la montée du
plateau de beille qui avant tout m
le vélo julien bénéteau est clos et le
compte
l'atout de beille tout
de babel dans les premiers lacets de la
montée finale français et espagnols
belges américains se partagent la route
du tour
formidable c'est vraiment dingue dingue
cette course est passionnante en
hollande tout le monde regarde à la télé
c'est énorme
chez nous on fait vous fait tous du vélo
on n'est pas nous c'est le forez dans le
camp espagnol
quatre coureurs du pays en tête au pied
du col
les meilleurs sont passés depuis de
longues minutes loin de la lutte pour la
victoire finale
les moins costauds se font attendre mais
force quand même l'admiration premier
comme les derniers bien sûr que
lorsqu'il le mairede autant que les
premiers airs mais ils font le tour le
dernier mérite autant que le premier ait
fait le tour
selon un récent sondage 80% des français
ne croient pas en l'honnêteté des
performances des coureurs mais ici les
sceptiques n'ont pas leur place
le sort de leurs proches on s'en fout
après il sait pas se passer tout le
monde est clair intéresse la france est
le dernier coureur est passé direction
la camionnette de l'udc
un belge équipé d'une petite télévision
là haut c'est un jeune espagnol du nom
de contador qui gagne l'état le plateau
de beille se vide peu à peu
une descente rythmée par les crises
espagnol à la gloire du vainqueur du
jour de la formule 1 avec la victoire
espagnole de fernando alonso sur le
circuit du nürburgring le pilote
espagnol signer sa troisième victoire de
la saison
kimi räikkönen a dû abandonner lewis
hamilton qui avait pris le départ de la
course après sa sortie de route lors des
essais n'a pas terminé dans les points
mais il conserve la tête du championnat
du monde pour deux petits points devant
son coéquipier alonso pour finir des
images de football et de franck ribéry
et les marseillais vont encore être un
peu plus nostalgiques le nouveau joueur
du bayern munich a plus que réussi ses
débuts sous le maillot bavarois de buts
en coupe de la ligue une passe décisive
et une influence réelle dans le jeu le
public et la presse ont été plus que
séduit le festival d'avignon qui se
tient jusqu'à la fin du mois coup de
projecteur ce soir sur le roi lear de
shakespeare la pièce est mise en scène
par jean françois sivadier dans la cour
d'honneur beaucoup de burlesque dans
cette tragédie
isabelle bechler guillaume viard
grandiloquence langue très verte et sang
versé en vain shakespeare est de retour
dans la cour d'honneur du palais des
papes
le roi lear qui veut partager son
royaume entre ses trois filles avant la
mort il fait résonner sa folie dites moi
mes filles de laquelle allons nous
pouvoir dire qu'elle nous aiment le plus
l'aîné d'abord puis la seconde vont se
déclarer
j'aime votre majesté comme je le dois
ni plus ni moins mais la plus jeune sa
préférée par le vrai et refuse la
flatterie aller battant loin de ma vue
et que la tombe soit pour moi la paix
dont l'erreur c'est de demander à ses
filles de faire une déclaration d'amour
de mélanger l'intimé et le public
cordelia et donc d hériter et banni mais
le vieux roi ne va pas trouver chez ses
fils aîné les preuves d'amour qu'il en
attend son fou est désormais son seul
ami
ces corps des liens qui revient en fou
et suisse perd son père quoi
voilà église proche trahison et fidélité
s'entrechoquent lire lui glisse dans la
folie et ne reconnaît pas ces anges
gardiens
il semble définitivement égaré
indifférent aux catastrophes qui l'a
provoquée la folie dans la pièce et
c'est pas une source de malheur c'est le
chemin vers la vérité
mais la guerre est inévitable et
l'hécatombe avec elle
ne reviendra plus jamais lire sur lui
par jean françois sivadier ou comment
par orgueil on peut rater définitivement
le coche de l'amour paternel et filiale
de la télévision au cinéma les simpson
vont franchir le pas cette semaine la
célèbre famille américaine après 20 ans
d'existence à la télévision s'invite
mercredi sur grand écran et apparemment
l'humour et la folie ambiante sont
toujours au rendez vous emmanuel lambert
frédéric capron le monde se prépare à
affronter l'indicible bon d'accord deux
indices ils sont jaunes et pas très joli
un peu à l'étroit les simpson après 18
ans passés dans la petite lucarne
il s'offre enfin la grande toile bart
lisa maggie marge homer la famille la
plus beauf de toute la galaxie
je crois que j'y touche les simpson un
phénomène dans le monde de l'animation
créée en 1989 par un jeune dessinateur
américain
la série est toujours présente vingt ans
plus tard on a dépassé les 400 épisodes
le succès est international puis de
caution spider cochon qui peut marcher
au plafond c'est parce qu'il ya une joie
universel à se sentir supérieur e à
l'épée pour votre vie a beau ne passe
d'être terrible ça ne sera jamais pire
que celles des simpson
l'autre force de cet univers son côté
caustique politiquement incorrect cette
fois ci c'est arnold scharzenegger le
président des états unis c'est moi ça
réccurent c'est la politique
environnementale américaine qui est
dénoncée au maire a causé une
catastrophe écologique sa ville doit
être détruite
9 c'est pas de garde mais c'est gratuit
c'est même pas ici connaissent bits
un couple ordinaire dans un cinéma
pas vraiment et oui ce sont eux les voix
françaises des simpson mariait la ville
comme à l'écran philippe et véronique
double homer et marge depuis le début
long métrage au bout de dix huit ans
arrive pour nous comme une consécration
puisque ont été les voix de l'ombre
pendant ses 18 ans et puis là maintenant
on se retrouve face à vous la table en
pleine lumière
humour renouveler pas de longueur les
simpson passe avec brio du petit écran
aux très grands une chose est sûre ils
nous font rire jaune
forcément avant de terminer journal as
disparition de notre collaborateur geof
il est décédé hier à l'âge de 52 ans il
est l origine du service infographie de
france 2 il s'était toujours impliqué
dans la vie sociale de cette chaîne nous
pensons à son épouse et à ses trois fils
voit la fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo valérie alexandre 20h50 trois
épisodes inédits de votre série urgences
demain à 13h olivier galzi à 20 heures
vous aurez le grand plaisir de retrouver
françoise laborde
je vous retrouve au mercredi soir pour
un jour un destin au sommaire de
documents sur deux révolte et daniel
balavoine et patrick dewaere très belle
soirée à vous
où